a great performance can leave a
permanent impression on moviegoers then
again bad acting can leave a similarly
permanent impression but for very
different reasons
of all the ridiculous scenes in the
Sylvester Stallone starring dystopian
disaster Judge Dredd none play out quite
as badly as the long-awaited
confrontation between Judge Dredd and
his brother Rico at the end of the movie
what begins is a slow burning war of
words quickly escalates to the point
where Stallone and Armando Sante forget
how to pronounce basic English why did
you judge me you killed the disappear
the means to an end you started a
message I caused the revolution betrayed
alone
not like Stallone has great grasp of
English to begin with
pretty much any scene from Showgirls is
bad enough to make this list but the one
that always sticks out as being the very
worst happens to be toward the beginning
of the movie when Nomi meets her future
roommate Molly for the first time as we
saw on Save By the Bell Elizabeth
Berkeley tends to crank each line up to
11.
Berkeley might have been channeling that
very scary moment when performing in
this scene when she vigorously files her
nails violently stabs her beverage and
pours ketchup over french fries as if
she's auditioning for a commercial about
anger management eventually Molly asked
where Nomi's from and that's when things
get really dramatic
where are you from
back east from where Becky's
places
it's a pretty extreme reaction huh but
maybe it's not the line of questioning
that's got her upset maybe she just
doesn't have the right snacks
doggy Chow
oh I used to love doggy Chow
I used to love doggy Chow too Nicholas
Cage's performance in the Wicker man is
so bad people who haven't even seen the
movie are able to quote Infamous lines
like this one
now why in the hell would you let them
do a sick thing like that things get
particularly loopy when Cage's character
a policeman who interrogates a group of
neo-pagans after his daughter goes
missing discovers a burned doll he
believes belonged to his daughter that's
when we get a glimpse into the Nicholas
Cage School of interrogation
what do you do when
doing down a crazy lady you deny your
accusations with the convictions and
believability of a four-year-old boy at
least that was Mark Wahlberg's plan
during his confrontation with Betty
Buckley and midnight shyamalan's The
Happening planning on stealing something
no ma'am we're not plan on murdering me
in my sleep what no even Wahlberg
himself admitted the movie sucked during
the press conference for the fighter two
years later you can't blame me for
wanting to play a science teacher you
know I wasn't playing a cop or a crook
Mark Wahlberg doing a bad job of acting
in a forgettable movie what no
picture the scenario you realize you're
about to be eaten alive by trolls what
do you do what do you say maybe you take
a cue from Arnold the nerdy teenager in
troll too and do something like this
they're eating her
and then they're going to eat me
[Music]
alas it was too late to save Arnold what
no sorry Mark Wahlberg there was nothing
we could do
skip to any random scene in the room
Tommy wiseau's writing acting and
directing debut from 2003 and it's
painfully bad in the very best way I did
not hit her I did not
oh hi Mark this film is so poorly
constructed that it's been dubbed The
Citizen Kane of bad movies making it
hard to narrow it down to just one
laughable scene chicken Peter you just a
little chicken
but the most popular best of the worst
moment came with sews cuckolded Johnny
confronts his thought to be cheating
fiance Lisa in this now iconic exchange
you're lying I never hit you you got
Tammy pot Lisa believe it or not
according to waso's co-star and friend
Greg cestero the moment was inspired by
James Dean who uttered a virtually
identical line and Rebel Without a Cause
you're tearing me apart you gotta tell
me apart Lisa who performed better we
think it's time for Tommy to celebrate
do you want me to order a pizza
whatever I don't care I already ordered
a pizza you think about everything just
about everyone involved in the
adaptation of Stephanie Myers vampire
romance could be accused of phoning it
in but Twilight's MVP Christian Stewart
takes top on us for worst performance in
the movies climactic scene it all starts
when a trio of nomadic Vamps lurk around
looking for something to eat when they
stumble across the Cullen Clan playing
baseball while they're protected human
pet watches on a standoff in shoes and
almost ends peacefully before James
catches a whiff of Bella and gets the
munchies
you brought a snack the situation is
diffused but not done James the track of
vampire vows to hunt her down and eat
her despite the Cullen's best efforts to
hide her he lures her away from the
Cullens and savagely snaps her leg
Bella's sparkly vampire boyfriend Edward
arrives to save her from sudden death
but James still manages to sink his
teeth into her arm the Venom from his
bite starts to spread through her veins
right away which is when she informed
everyone
in Maya's book the pain is described as
quote EX Exquisite but watching
Stewart's grunting and grimacing in the
moment makes those tiny teeth marks look
anything but Richard linklet is coming
of age classic Dazed and Confused gave
us the gift of many quotable Matthew
McConaughey moments you just gotta keep
living man
l-i-v-i-n but it's also responsible for
the unbearable nuisance of Mitch Kramer
the goober freshman is a categorical
case study in Social awkwardness so
there's some lack of screen Savvy to be
expected from his betrayal but in the
scene where he's trying to flirt with
Sabrina outside the Emporium It's Full
Tilt Amateur hour instead of coming out
with traditional acting devices like
facial expressions vocal inflection or
pure presence actor Wiley Wiggins relied
on eight yes eight cringe-worthy nose
grabs
what are you doing here you just been
doing
and one super clumsy elbow nudged to
Coast through the scene link later
eventually accepted responsibility for
letting this bad slip through the
editing cracks telling The Daily Beast I
just thought the nose grab was kind of
an awkward gesture I'm the director so
it's on me that's the thing people
notice only if it's the third time you
watch it I just thought it was that
young awkward man kind of thing maybe it
was one or two too many when it comes to
removing a few of those nose grabs maybe
on a remastered cut of the movie well
it'd be a lot cooler if you did
considering Gili is a movie who's six
percent Rotten Tomatoes score is
probably a little generous there are a
lot of awful aspects to choose from you
know some you're right
it is sadness it's sadness and I'm sad
the stupidity of this thing extends all
the way up to the title itself so it's a
tall order to pick just one scene as the
worst of the worst since Julie was such
a turkey at the box office though it
makes sense to focus on the scene that
tried and failed miserably to make
Thanksgiving themed Cuisine a workable
piece of sexy dialogue in the movie
Jennifer Lopez plays a lesbian named
Ricky who decides to make Ben Affleck's
Hitman her boy toy and invites him into
her bed like so it's turkey time
huh
that's when everyone watching this movie
did this
the turkey talk is an evergreen
highlight for both Ben and Jen's career
blooper reels even though they've tried
to put the picture into perspective ever
since yeah there's worse movies than
Julie out there with old due respective
Brad Pitt his performance in seven is a
classic case of an actor completely
missing the emotional Mark of an
important movie moment instead of
delivering on what might have been a
powerful scene he made a bit of a
mockery of himself to be fair to Pitt he
was working with three industry Giants
director David Fincher and actors Kevin
Spacey and Morgan Freeman while he was
still something of the Hollywood
newcomer at the time but compared to
everyone else's delivery in the Wrath
scene his contribution is pretty
inexcusable in the grand finale of John
Doe's deadly sins inspired plan Kevin
Spacey's killer character leads the
detective Duo out to the desert to find
a package containing something Freeman's
character gets a gander at it first and
is faced dutifully reflects the Grim
reality of the situation we're led to
believe it's the head of Mill's pregnant
wife Tracy an innocent and lovely lady
who has nothing to do with any of this
mess but we never get to see the
contents the tension is staggering until
Pitt starts screaming his lines and
jumping around like a carnival clown saw
you with a box what was in the bar
what's in the box
it's a scene Ruiner upon re-watching it
looking back you might be tempted to
believe it was secretly Pitt's talent
that was actually hidden in the box if
Keanu Reeves could really take a Bill
and Ted style Journey back in time we
hope he'd at least consider returning to
the early 90s and undoing everything he
did in Bram Stoke as Dracula at the very
least he should retroactively hire
himself a proper dialect coach because
his British accent is so horrible that
it actually distracts viewers from
fixating on Gary oldman's giant butt wig
which is Quite a feat in one scene in
particular Reeves character starts to
realize that the count is bad news and
delivers a recap of his Transylvanian
Adventures that's way funnier than it's
supposed to be I've seen many strange
things already bloody wolves chasing me
through some blue Inferno even director
Francis Ford Coppola who's practically
president of the Keanu Reeves fan club
had to admit to Entertainment Weekly it
was tough for him to affect an English
accent he tried so hard that was the
problem actually he wanted to do it
perfectly and in trying to do it
perfectly it came off as stilted in
other words I doubted everything
even my mind
I was impotent with fear 1999 presented
two major moving moments depicting Sons
rejecting their stodgy old dad's wishes
for them to follow in their footsteps
and one of those things was not like the
other Jake Gyllenhaal's breakthrough
performance as Homer Hickman in October
Sky features him standing up to the
status quo of going to the mine shaft
after school with his Dad instead he
literally reaches for the sky as a
wannabe space cadet who built rockets on
the sly it builds to a poignant moment
of father-son friction that totally
resonates the way it should
command your life it's not mine
[Music]
compare that to James Van the big
Showdown with his own pop in Varsity
Blues which hit theaters a few weeks
before in the movie Van Der Beek plays a
backup High School quarterback named MOX
who's hiked his way to the starting
Squad after an injury takes out the
team's original Star somehow this
ignites some long-held stream his dad
has for Marks to become the star player
but MOX has no such Ambitions and tells
him as much in the most exaggerated and
terrible accent imaginable playing
football at West Keenan may have been
the opportunity of your lifetime
but I don't want your life it's hard to
tell whether it's the dull delivery tone
or the lines themselves that make this
such a dud but he gets no points for
that scene James Franco made a jump to
the Blockbuster A-list with Sam raimi's
Spider-Man trilogy but it's also a
regular go-to source for some of his
most accidentally lousy acting moments
his character spends the first sequel
Desperately Seeking the web slinging
vigilante who he believes killed his dad
in the first film and when he lifts The
Mask to reveal spidey's identity he
discovers his best friend Peter Parker
is his new worst enemy
awkward footwork is only exceeded in
Badness by his whispered threats about
getting Payback
if only I could cause you the pain that
you've caused me the whole thing adds up
to a scene more cartoonish than the
comics it was based on Andy McDowell
never quite lived up to the promise she
displayed in movies from the late 80s
and early 90s maybe it was because of a
wooden performance in Four Weddings and
a funeral I don't usually skulk a lot
but I suppose I could skulk if scorpion
were required although the film is
otherwise moderately Charming there's
one scene that tends to ruin it on every
rear watch at the end of the movie in
the pouring rain Hugh Grant delivers one
of those classic sappy it was you all
along speeches to McDowell but his
monologue is interrupted by one very
pointless observation
is it still
raining so little emotion in the moment
from McDowell that it's almost as if she
were the funeral featured in the film's
title
[Music]